Harry this is a fantastic four and you
play a company geezer and it don't news
though love yeah so having your for
Devon originally aren't you so how did
you find doing the accent well it was
fine I've lived in London for years so
hopefully something that's more off yeah
and you and Rasmus play brothers in the
film don't you and you're always getting
him into trouble if it's a really funny
little montage worried so it shows all
those moments what is it like him
fingers during that montage yeah end of
the first week was disappointing running
away from some of Andy's kind of salient
gonna ask you what do you what do you
like in real life with your own brother
also getting him into trouble all the
time no I don't know no not anymore very
well-behaved yes now he was the most
mysterious person on set because he
obviously it's a film that has a really
good vibe about having a gory atmosphere
on saying it I mean he was amazing he
would be sat in his deck chair and it'd
be like Richard gonna do take and he'd
be like just up do it and completely
incredible doing one and we were all
just like Ryan I say do it
did you see the scene where he's
powering a Zimmer frame being chased by
zombies yeah yeah we I think well I
think we were making I think we were
high tailing across London at that point
but yes I've seen it and I think it's
hilarious I think a news Ian is in a
frame is a combination that should
happen you know
talking about weapons if there were a
zombie apocalypse what would be your
weapon of choice oh no a drone to just
follow them around and sort of I'd go
aerial probably or a big plane with
massive bombs I don't know if those
they're sketchy I don't like this I mean
it's pretty arm to arm combat I wouldn't
refer to look at that close to do you
think cuz James has got a whole plan the
rights for the film whole plan so
stabbed how it worked
do you think you'd be good in Anna's
ambience bro well if I found mental
Mickey's lock up and found the
ridiculous level of ammunition they had
in there then I think I feel safe
otherwise I don't know what makes the
constant I mean France nice the
camaraderie on set I think that's part
of the story why the script was appear
too appealing was because there is this
this this lovely connection between the
you know the older generation and the
younger generation and so you put that
in the story then you have to achieve
that so therefore you do have this older
group of actor to the younger magazine
so you you're kind of symmetry to what's
going on the story in this and it's
sweet and it's quite rare to kind of
have that now often you know you might
play you play with children and parents
or it's Paris an older thing but to a
circle there's a cool dynamic to have to
have them
I know you've learned you've learnt many
kind of things for previous roles you've
had whether it be the drums or what have
you the only thing you had to learn for
companies versus zombies kebobs gearing
a zombie with your samurai swords that
was that was 20 minutes telling us what
it takes 20 minutes and you'll be an
expert we look forward to coming up next
from you I know you've been working on
the live range haven't you
I've been doing the moment I did a thing
in South Africa called fly to the stalks
which is a two-part TV thing and then
there's the Ranger which is Disney's big
epic Western which has been truly
amazing experience so far we're still
finishing it so there's a little bit of
time left so in terms of Lone Ranger one
can we look forward to that do you think
and don't lecture and so you had it like
a six-week cowboy camp for that as well
talking about learning thing yeah we had
to learn to ride horses for that so that
was that was amazing something you took
to naturally that it feel like you
you've always been connected to or I
don't know I think it's different from
playing cowboy manure when you're a kid
but you know it was it was certainly I
felt very humbled and privileged about
to get to learn to ride it so yeah we
look forward to lots more from you Harry
and thanks so much for talking to us
you